Now that we know how to load images into the canvas,
let's start thinking about how we're actually going to start drawing on that.
To do so, I've gone ahead and changed out the code over here.
And instead of the image, I've switched in the methods fill rectangle and
stroke rectangle.
I've also made the canvas a little bit bigger if you're following along.
Fill rectangle and stroke rectangle work fairly, similarly.
Got their starting x and
y coordinates and then their widths and heights all patched in a parameters.
So let's go ahead and see what these two look like.
I will come over here and open up this document.
Cmd+O > Stroke Canvas > Open.
And we see that this code creates two different rectangles.
The filled rectangle starts at 100, 100 and has a width of 100, 100 and
that's this big black rectangle right here.
And the stroke rectangle starts at 50, 50 and is 50 by 50 pixels wide.
And that's this gray rectangle right here.
Or I guess you could call them squares,
because they have the same widths and heights.
But either way, this demo is to show that filled rectangles are filled in
with colors while stroke rectangles are not.